[Music]
with 193 million subscribers worldwide
netflix has transformed the tv and film
industry
part of its success is down to reid
hastings
netflix's ceo who has pioneered a
radical management style
he allows unlimited holiday expects
every employee to vie for their position
and tells them to never ever try to
please their boss
it's reid hastings welcome to the
economist asks thank you so much what a
pleasure well in your book
no rules rules you lay out a very
unconventional way
that you run the company you call it a
unique cultural experiment now there's a
bold claim
what does that mean in practice well you
know for 300 years the factory
has dominated our economy and so it's
natural that the factory metaphor the
top-down boss
all the rules a focus on efficiency
becomes the dominant paradigm for
management but
when your company is really about idea
generation
about creativity there's a different way
to manage there's a different way to
lead
and so we tell people don't manage try
to inspire
try to support and we do get some chaos
and we do get some mistakes but we also
get some great
ideas that help us evolve and stay
relevant
if you don't try to you're told not to
please your boss doesn't that
mean that the employee has to kind of
figure out quite a lot of themselves and
also it induces a kind of nervousness
that they might
not be pleasing their boss because they
don't really know what they're supposed
to be doing anyway the goal is to get
people to think about what's best
for the company how do we grow how do we
please our members
ever more and we want people to be
independent thinkers
we don't want them to ever hide anything
from their manager
but we want them to be thinking about
how can we do things better
and that first principle thinking is
what's helped netflix
evolve through so many changes isn't it
a recipe for
being cautious if you're worried that
you will get fired if you're seen
to not be performing at a level it seems
a bit harder to figure out
what is required of you most of our
industrial culture
is not really focused on creativity it's
focused on error prevention
and that's good if you're an airline or
a hospital
okay but if you're a creative
organization what you want to do
is make it safe for people to make
mistakes and to try things
sort of managing on the edge of chaos
where you're very creative
but it hasn't actually tipped into chaos
you know we
model ourselves on professional sports
where you want the team to really work
well together
and to play their heart out i mean
athletes know that they can be injured
at any moment but they don't focus on it
they focus on how do they play the best
game that they can
and our employees are similar they focus
on how do they have an incredible
professional experience
learn a lot grow an incredible amount
and change the company for the better
you're known to be quite quick to fire
people
is that a fair reputation no i think
we're very considered and thoughtful but
we do say
that everybody's playing for their
position and that's how you get
championship performance
is being able and willing to take the
tough steps
and what about things like allocated
leave or not having allocated leave
could be a bit of an urban myth but is
it the case if i were a netflix employee
i just
make up my own leave allocation and how
does that work what does it motivate
we encourage people to take holiday and
to refresh and recharge
but we don't manage how much they take
so formally it's
unlimited holiday they can do whatever
they want
and we leave it to people's judgment but
i would say we encourage everyone to
set a good example and uh to
take vacation and to think broadly and
you know also to read and exercise and
you know just generally be healthy
what's the thing in potentially coming
back to a view of management theory that
feels it does feel quite distinctively
like something that
you would want to wrap your arms around
but i wondered if are you the same
kind of manager that you were when you
made your way up to the
head of one of the world's top streaming
services what have you learned and
what's been the painful learning well
the painful learning was in my first
company
which was about 30 years ago was a
technical software company and i wrote
about this in the book
every time someone made a mistake i put
a process in place
so we didn't make that mistake again and
over time we can
get filled with process and we had the
people
who liked following process and then the
market shifted
and we were unable to adapt because
people weren't thinking about
the right thing for the business they
were thinking about following the
process
and that's when i realized that if you
optimize for efficiency
you don't have much flexibility and for
a creative business that's going to
change a lot
it's better to focus on flexibility and
tolerate less efficiency kind of
managing
on the edge of chaos thank you very much
for joining us reid hastings
pleasure you can listen to the full
interview in our podcast
the economist asks every week we talk to
a high profile
figure click the link opposite to find
this episode and
thanks for watching
[Music]
you